noch eine letzte bemerkung wenn ich sie
sagen darf weil mich das sehr gefreut
hat gestern abend das ist gut
jenseits des impfens dass die pflege
jetzt in der primetime läuft die
pflegekräfte in deutschland leisten
extrem viel eher durch die pandemie
wurde uns das noch mal sehr sehr
deutlich gemacht und ich finde es gut
dass dieser einsatz auch in echtzeit
jetzt auch über mehrere stunden
nachvollziehbar geworden ist im tv und
das zeigt uns eben auch wie wichtig ist
es wahrzunehmen was da übrigens auf den
intensivstationen
seit mittlerweile sechs monaten in
dauerbelastung geleistet wird zur
behandlung von kurven 19 patienten die
zahl der kopf 19 patienten ist nochmal
stark gestiegen
und deswegen ist die auszahlung des
corona bonus der eine teil jetzt ja zum
zweiten mal genauso wichtig ist aber vor
allem eine bessere bezahlung bessere
arbeitsbedingungen auf dauer für die
20er jahre damit haben wir schon vor der
pandemie begonnen das wollen wir nach
der pandemie und in der pandemie auch
fortsetzen was dort geleistet wird zeigt
die dokumentation sehr eindrucksvoll
pflegerinnen und pfleger verdienen
unseren respekt und sagt danke schön
aber vor allem eben bessere
arbeitsbedingungen und damit gerade nach
dieser schweren phase der pandemie auch
viele in dem beruf bleiben und
idealerweise zurückkehren wollen werden
wir auch zügig in gesprächen mit den
pflegeverbänden weiter darüber beraten
wie wir auch dafür die
arbeitsbedingungen noch weiter
verbessern können
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren